NAZMAL IDRIS: Welcome
to this episode of UXT,
where we're going to
learn more about lean UX
and why it's important
in creating products
that people love.
I'm your host, Nazmal Idris.
I have a very special guest
with me today, Laura Klein,
author of "UX for
Lean Startups."
Welcome to the show?
LAURA KLEIN: Hello, internets.
NAZMAL IDRIS: Before we
start talking about lean UX,
we should perhaps address
lean startup first.
So Laura, what is Lean Startup?
LAURA KLEIN: So lean
startup is a methodology
that was created by Eric Ries.
And it's based on
lean manufacturing,
which actually
came out of Toyota.
Lean startup this about
learning as quickly as possible
and reducing the cycle
time through what's
called the
build-measure-learn loop.
The idea is that,
instead of just assuming
that you know exactly
what you should build,
you form a hypothesis
that something might work.
And then you find the fastest
way to validate or invalidate
the hypothesis.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
LAURA KLEIN: The
goal, of course,
is to create things
that people want to use
and that they will actually buy.
And we do that by
learning and validating
our ideas at every
step of the way.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So Laura, word on the street is
that I can make some products
very quickly, and on the
cheap, without spending money
on design using this
lean startup thing.
Is that true?
LAURA KLEIN: No.
It is not true.
I know it's terrible,
that it isn't.
But it's absolutely not true.
Because lean startup, really,
it's not about being cheap.
And it's not about being
free, or cutting corners.
And just because you're
bootstrapping your startup
doesn't make you lean.
I mean, OK, so it turns out
lean startups can end up
spending less money and
time than other startups.
But that's because
they are constantly
evaluating whether they're
building the right thing.
And that minimizes waste.
Just saving money or going
fast does not make you lean.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So what is Lean EX?
How is it different
than lean startup?
LAURA KLEIN: Lean UX
is really just a way
to apply those iterative methods
to the user experience design
practice.
Doing Lean UX means that you're
always validating with users
that you're designing something
that people are going to use.
It's about designing
products that
are both usable and useful.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So you wrote a book
about this, right?
So what type of an audience
would find this book useful?
LAURA KLEIN: So right.
The book is called "UX
for Lean Startups."
But it's not actually
just for UX designers.
And it's not even really
just for startups.
So I don't.
Maybe I could have
named it better.
But the book is
really for anybody
who's building a product because
design is everybody's job.
It gives you a lot
of tips and tools
for learning from your users
and turning that understanding
into great products that
people will actually buy.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
Design is everyone's
responsibility.
We say that a lot on this show.
So Laura, if I want a Lean UX
organization in my company,
how do I go about
making that happen?
LAURA KLEIN: Well, if
you're a big company
with a lot of siloed
organizations,
you know, UX in one silo,
engineering in another,
marketing in another, it
can be really big change.
But even if you're a
startup with one designer
and three people
in a room, there
are some fundamental things
that you need to get right.
The ones that I think
are most important
are thinking in terms of
hypotheses and assumptions
and learning to validate those
before you commit to building.
Creating cross
functional teams that
include engineering, design,
research, product management,
and whoever else needs to
be involved in these product
decisions.
You need an environment where
you can measure and test
all of your design
and product decisions
and a team that's
open to understanding
the real impact they're
having on end users.
You also need a really
different approach
to design deliverables,
where you're only
creating artifacts that are
necessary for communication.
You're not making little
pixel perfect mockups
for every single change.
And finally, you need
support from the top
of your organization
because you're
going to have to change
your whole way of thinking
about products.
You need product
managers and designers
to be held accountable
for the impact
that their decisions
have on the end user.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
LAURA KLEIN: I
mean, you no longer
get evaluated on whether
a feature ships or not.
You get evaluated based on
whether the changes you make
positively impact user behavior.
And that's a big
change that needs
to happen at the very
top of the organization.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That is so true.
So Laura, can you talk
more about validating
assumptions and hypotheses?
That sounds really important,
but it also sounds complicated.
What does it mean, exactly?
LAURA KLEIN: So it's a
really big part of Lean UX.
And it's a big change
in the way we work.
We have to stop
assuming that we know
exactly what we're building.
Instead, we need
to frame everything
as a hypothesis that's going to
be validated before we commit
those coding resources.
NAZMAL IDRIS: So can you
explain that with an example?
LAURA KLEIN: I can.
So here's something that,
I think, a lot of us
can probably identify with.
I want you to imagine
that you've got a product.
And your product manager
comes in and says,
our product needs more social.
Make it more social.
Let's add comments.
NAZMAL IDRIS: Isn't
everything better with social?
LAURA KLEIN: Everything
is better with social.
But see, what happens is
that the manager comes up
with a brilliant, brand
new idea for comments.
And then the designers
immediately dive in.
And they start thinking, OK,
how do I make the ideal comments
experience?
And the engineers go, OK, great.
How do I write this
code so that it's
a really fast, stable
comments experience.
But instead, what
we should be asking
is how do we know whether
this is even the right thing
to build in the first place?
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
LAURA KLEIN: See, the
whole comments feature
has a lot of assumptions
packed into it.
For example, there's
this assumption
that, by making the
product more social,
our key metrics are
going to improve.
Do we really know that?
Do we know that adding
a comments feature
is going to improve
our business?
Do we even know that people
are going to leave comments?
In other words, do comments
fulfill either a user
need, or a business need,
or, even better, both.
We can't just don't assume
that those things are
true because the product
manager had an idea.
Instead of assuming
that those are facts,
we're going to treat
them as hypotheses,
and we're going to test
them as quickly as possible.
And ideally, we're
going to test them
without building the
entire comments feature,
and then launching, and
just seeing how it does.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So these are hypotheses.
How do we validate them?
LAURA KLEIN: So
this is where we run
into a really common lean
startup buzz word-- MVP.
NAZMAL IDRIS: I've heard that.
LAURA KLEIN: Yeah, we
need to build an MVP.
And MVP is a Minimum
Viable Product.
It's the smallest
possible thing that we
can build that will help
us to learn whether or not
our hypothesis is true.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense
I've heard of these MVPs.
So are they just really
crappy versions of products?
LAURA KLEIN: They are not.
NAZMAL IDRIS: Ah.
LAURA KLEIN: So this is
a common misconception.
But an MVP is never a
crappy version of a product.
Because it turns out that
the only thing that we learn
from crappy products
is that people
don't like crappy products.
That's a well-validated
hypothesis.
We know that people
hate crappy things.
The word viable is actually
there for a reason.
It's got be something
that we can learn from.
NAZMAL IDRIS: No,
That makes sense.
So what is the MVP version
of this comments feature?
LAURA KLEIN: That's
a good question.
There are actually a few
different versions of the MVP.
And you could start
with any of them,
sort of depending on what
you want to validate first.
So for example, if you wanted to
validate whether anybody would
leave a comment
at all, you might
create what we call a fake
door, or a feature stub?
NAZMAL IDRIS: What
is a fake door?
LAURA KLEIN: So if you want
to validate whether anybody's
going to use
something, you build
the very first interaction
with that feature.
And then you record whether
anybody interacts with it.
So in this case,
you might put a box
on the page that's a
little comment box.
And it's got a little button
that says Add a Comment.
And you let people
Add a Comment.
But instead of
Adding the Comment
to the page immediately, you
might just give the answer
a nice Thank You message saying,
you're reviewing the comment.
And then you'd send the
comment in an email to you.
That way, you'd know whether
anybody tried to leave one.
It's a lot faster than
building the whole system,
with flagging, and blocking,
and moderation, and everything,
and then realizing that
nobody has anything to say.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So that's a quick
way to validate.
Now what if people actually
start leaving comments,
like they actually
engage with this feature?
LAURA KLEIN: Yeah,
so once you've
validated that people are
interested in starting
this process and
leaving comments,
the next minimum
viable product might
be to see whether adding some
of those products to the page
actually makes a
different in your metrics.
So remember, you've
got some comments
that people have emailed to you.
And so you could add
those to the page by hand
and then doing an
A/B test to see
if the comments you've
added make a different.
For example, show the same
page with comments and without
and see if more people buy on
the page that has comments.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So what you're saying is
that the idea of an MVP
is to learn whether a feature
or product is likely to succeed
before you actually
put in the resources
to completely build it.
LAURA KLEIN: Yeah.
That's exactly right.
That's 100% true.
And that's really what
this whole thing is about.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So now, after the
MVP, how do you
know when your hypotheses
and assumptions have
been validated?
LAURA KLEIN: That's
an excellent question.
And it's also a huge question
with a lot of answers to it.
The basic idea is
if you have to be
able to measure your
results in some way.
And if you can't tell what
effect your changes are having
on real user behavior,
you can't actually
ever know whether your design
decisions were any good.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So can you illustrate
that with an example.
LAURA KLEIN: Sure.
So let's say you end up
shipping that comments feature
that we've been talking about.
In most place, you
just ship the feature
and then move on
to the next one.
But what if, for some reason
that you don't necessarily
understand, when this
feature is out in the wild,
comments really end up
hurting your product?
NAZMAL IDRIS: Whoa.
LAURA KLEIN: Yeah, I know,
so, maybe, it sounds weird.
But maybe people are so
busy commenting on things
that they don't buy anything.
Or maybe comments make
the page load really slow.
And you end up
driving people away.
There could be any
number of reasons
that a feature might fail.
But the point is
that you don't know
it fails unless
you are measuring.
NAZMAL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So is this where you
might use A/B testing?
LAURA KLEIN: A/B
testing is really
the best way to test the real
impact that your changes have
on your product.
But there are other ways, both
qualitative and quantitative,
to validate your changes.
NAZMAL IDRIS: Ah, that
sounds like something we
should talk about
in future episodes.
LAURA KLEIN: I
think you're right.
NAZMAL IDRIS: Cool.
Well, thank you so much
for being on the show.
If you want to learn
more about Lean UX
before we make more
episodes on it,
don't forget to read Laura's
book "UX for Lean Startups,"
where she will teach you
all about making products
that people love.
LAURA KLEIN: Thanks everybody.
Go build something amazing.
NAZMAL IDRIS: And thank you,
Laura, again, for being here.
And thank you for watching.
Good bye.